no offense this time on Bandit Patrol
two Raptors rescued
but one flat out refuses to Wrangle prey
in the wild you're gonna have to fight
for your food if they cannot take live
parade they will starve to death then a
litter of curious Critters are you guys
hungry turns into tag team rehab I think
I have the easy job and she thinks she
has the easy job come on open it it's a
win-win and oh my gosh what happened to
you a paralyzed skunk fights to regain
her footing we're gonna do it we're
gonna save her
foreign
[Music]
the sun is shining on the Waters of
Yellow Creek Park in Owensboro Kentucky
which one is it the lighter color beak
okay licensed Wildlife rehabilitators
Kristen Allen and her son Grant are on a
mission to help a not so lucky duck mom
why are you eating the bread we're gonna
feed the ducks with it's good bread
We're not gonna eat this whole thing
sharing is nice mom
here you go guys
we get a call about a duck that has a
fishing line wrapped around it and a
hook in its feet every time I walk up to
the lake the geese start going Hong Kong
it's that lady in the pink shirt again
if they just understand that I'm trying
to help them it would just be so much
easier but they don't understand people
so they talk and I chase
here you go guys come on
I mean it's close enough just grab it
you gotta do something
all right I got them
here we go
you want to hold him
oh yeah okay
all right oh bless his little heart uh
it looks like it's swollen so it's been
in there for a day or two it looks like
[Music]
foreign
look at his mouth for a second
I'm just seeing somebody was fishing and
the duck decided to go get the bait and
it got stuck in his mouth and the guy
just cut the fishing line so the duck
was stuck with the fishing hook and then
got the line wrapped around his leg okay
you've even got sinkers on you dude I'm
gonna hold his head I'll get his foot
you're free
let's go to your friends they're right
over there go on
[Music]
[Laughter]
what did they do when you tell me all
about it oh
cutest thing ever
it only took us about an hour to get
this duck which usually it takes way
longer than that but to spend one hour
of my time to help a duck that'll make
his life better it is so worth it
that wasn't bad that was much easier
than it usually is
[Music]
no two animal rescues are ever the same
you are the cutest little thing ever and
no one knows this better than licensed
Wildlife rehabilitator Nikki Christian
whose latest arrival a litter of
raccoons were found orphaned at a nearby
Farm Hey JC
I need your help babe come here look who
we just got in
caring for Animals just comes natural to
me it's what I was born to do my
daughter JC has the same passionate same
drive that I do it makes me proud to
watch how she is with animals she can
understand them even better than I can
what's that
let's take
do me a favor just in case they're more
go get me some alcohol so I can drop
them in there
out in the wild the mom raccoons
actually pick the ticks and any of the
parasites off of the babies the fact
that these raccoons have ticks on them
makes me think that the mom was probably
gone for a few days
ticks love to hide in between their
fingers but there's one right there
me and those are tiny their hands are so
sensitive a raccoon's Four Paw is nearly
as sensitive as a human's hand
okay babe we're almost done
if you don't mind to please go get
warmer medicine for them and then get
some electrolytes for me no we have a
goodness
any raccoons that come in I give them
dewormer and electrolytes the dewormers
can protect them from any worms in
parasites they might have got all kinds
of good stuff in there for them the
electrolytes help with dehydration and
the lack of food and water
you don't want to give them milk right
away if you don't know how long it's
been since they've ate we kind of want
to get everything activated and going
again
baby raccoons need to be fed every three
hours that means through the night as
well and with my nursing job I just
don't have the time to do it so they're
actually going to go to Nancy for a
little while and she's going to get them
good fat and sassy and bring them back
to me let's just kind of get them by
until Nancy can get them
[Music]
meanwhile at the Allen House Kristen's
daughter and licensed rehabber Adrian
has brought home a new feathered friend
mom we have another bar now let's see
smaller than the other one come here
baby
so what happened to him did they say
they cut down the tree and the baby fell
out of the hole
[Music]
a lot of times barred owls make their
nests in Hollow trees so probably what
happened to this barred owl is that
after the tree was cut down the parents
abandoned him and so he was basically
left for dead
it feels good
you're a little bit smaller than carrion
lucky for this bar now two weeks ago we
got another barred owl that we named
Harriet we're going to put these two
barred owls together in this enclosure
that Grant made it's basically a hollow
tree just like they had in the wild
ready bud
and you get to see your new friends
you're quite a bit smaller
[Music]
are they looking at each other
no
I'm putting this Plexiglas between them
initially just to make sure that they're
going to get along at this age Birds of
Prey can get aggressive especially if
food is scarce so it's really important
that we provide them with lots of food
and that they get to know each other
before we actually put them together
all right let me get a mouse and see if
we can get this guy to eat
out in the wild baby Bard owls eat
rodents and other small mammals which
their parents feed to them in the nest
when I stick my hand in there I don't
want anyone to see a human hand it's
going to seem a little owl puppet
instead
[Music]
you take it yep you took it he's hungry
he's hungry do you think you should pay
Harriet too so that she doesn't feel
left out yep
what do you think we should name
something
no I don't want to name it doesn't so
cute we're gonna keep Harriet Tubman in
this nesting stump until they're about
five or six weeks old because that's
about the age that they would fledge The
Nest then we're gonna take them to
Western Kentucky Raptor Center so they
can really spread their wings
a hundred miles away in Louisville
Kentucky looking good looking good
licensed Wildlife rehabber Brigette
Williams starts her day by repairing
some collision damage on an injured
Turtle this little guy had been on over
by a car Michelle is really broke all
the way through
this is a fiberglass car repair kit I
bought it at a car repair store they
asked me what kind of car I Was
preparing
with Wildlife rehabilitating you
definitely have to think out of the box
you have to do creative things and just
over years of experience you pretty much
learn what is going to work
he's not going to have it ingested just
just going on the shell surface but this
is going to harden it is going to be
essentially just attached to a shell
so that piece will stay on forever it
will yep
once he's all done he is going to go
back in the same spot where he's found
off the road though I remember being a
child and finding a turtle and it was
the most exciting Adventure ever
it doesn't matter what type of wildlife
it is it deserves a chance of life
Turtles included
okay I think we're good
Turtle tuned up Brigette hits the road
to rescue another animal who needs her
help two little skunks have been
wondering about a local Nursery
I am in a hurry because one of the
employees were only given an hour to
find other means of getting rid of these
skunks before an animal extract or
company comes it's very important for me
to get to this Nursery before the animal
extractor company because I know the end
result is not always life that is
offered to these animals
we saw him running okay why I'm here
okay came down to the stick food okay
when was the low so that goes all the
way to that busy road too they think the
mama Stone got hit by a car where was
the oh I think I see one it's on the
other side of the fence though
it's in their yard
I might have to go around and ask these
people if I can go in their yard I'm
just going to take a look over to see if
I see two
you know what it's going to be near
impossible to get him over here they're
under a big log pile right now
I thought this was going to be an easy
rescue but this little baby skunk is
proving to be quite difficult to get I'm
gonna have to show a little bit more
patience and wait it out
[Music]
thank you
sir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
oh my gosh what happened to you
in Louisville Kentucky the orphaned baby
skunk Wildlife rehabilitator Bridgette
Williams just rescued his hurt badly oh
gosh her little back legs are just
oh
you can see her drag wounds so she's
been doing this for a little while
this little girl is in big trouble she
has some open and infected wounds and
her little legs are just non-responsive
she needs some help ASAP I'm leaving
some instructions for the employees on
what to do if they should come upon this
other skunk but for now I have to get
this little girl back because she is in
bad shape
[Music]
she has some Flags by her feet she has a
big Lop right here fly eggs on a live
animal is a bad sign I'm trying to get
these off quickly they hatch very soon
after the fly lays them they turn into
maggots and they do start burning down
into her flesh and start eating flesh
I'm sure the Flies thought this little
gal is close to dying
I know it's scary
if I didn't find her I'd probably say
she would have lasted maybe another day
or two and that's it
I'm so glad I was able to get this skunk
but she just does not look good it
worries me that she is so unresponsive I
plan on calling a vet and getting her
over there right away
[Music]
as a mother of two licensed Wildlife
rehabber Nancy Reynolds is used to
taking care of crying babies are you
ready to eat but these baby starlings
give a whole new meaning to
round-the-clock care baby birds are
definitely a full-time job they have to
eat every 30 minutes
it is really important for me to keep up
a crazy feeding schedule with these
Birds because their metabolism is really
high so they have to eat from daylight
till dark these little babies were
actually found underneath a semi truck I
guess it had set for a little while so
the mom had made a nest had time to
hatch the babies but they decided to use
that truck and when they come in with
the shipments and ladies that were
unloading the truck heard the babies
crying and found the nest under there I
can't believe they were actually in this
huge truck going down the road probably
on a highway and those birds didn't fall
out of that Nest they're still so active
and Lively I mean I don't know how they
made it these baby birds are actually
going to go to the wildlife sanctuary
where they have somebody that specially
does birds and has time to do this all
day long
with the baby starlings taken care of
it's time for Nancy to head for Nikki's
house to be a surrogate parent all over
again Nikki called and said she had some
raccoons that she needed some help with
when she gets tiny babies in that need
every two three hour feedings she can't
do those because she works a lot so she
gives me the smaller babies our
relationship Works beautifully because I
think I have the easy job and she thinks
she has the easy job so it's a win-win
I don't know look at that I mean
seriously
these raccoon babies are around three to
four weeks old at this age they have to
grow and get healthy and strong need a
lot of attention right now go ahead and
give him murmur for the round arm they
had all kinds of little ticks in between
their little fingers we got those out
and I just gave them some electrolytes
all right I don't want to give them up
I'm going to see him I know
Nancy's gonna have her hands full for
the next couple of weeks but when she
gets them eating solid food then I'll
get them back and then I get to teach
them the things they need to know to
survive in the wild
thanks sorry I appreciate it very much I
know they're in good hands
[Music]
are you ready to eat
lunch at home Nancy and her daughter
Whitney begin feeding the raccoon kids a
routine they'll repeat several times a
day for the next few months you can't
chew you gotta suck on it
I'm gonna hold his little nose just a
little bit so he can suck on it when
he's just chewing in the beginning
getting a baby raccoon to take the
bottle is not as easy as it looks some
of them will bite it and chew on it and
it takes a couple of times to get them
to eat
all right
[Music]
I'm feeling better
[Music]
get your belly full
with the baby raccoons we always try to
burp them just because when you eat out
of a bottle it does get air in your
belly it does that for babies and
everybody else
all right Whitney's got the dirty job
today you ain't going to win it go potty
your turn
she gets stimulated to use the bathroom
in the wild their mom would lick them
and make them go we're gonna use baby
wipe and make them use the bathroom
when you get babies in this young is a
lot of late nights and a lot of feedings
a lot of booties to be wiped there is a
whole lot to do all right let's trade
when they're eating on their own they're
off the bottles they will be ready to go
back to Nikki's
no you've had your food
[Music]
after three weeks of getting to know
each other fledgling barred owls Harriet
and Tubman are like two peas in a pod
baby with your brother
and your sister
I wasn't real worried when I removed
that plexiglass because Harriet and
Tubman were getting along great they're
eating well they're getting their flight
feathers and they're getting along just
like brothers and sisters all right guys
let's go they're ready to go to Western
Kentucky Raptor Center and then the real
challenges begin for them
foreign
[Music]
is it heavy
I built it for Easy Transport that's
good
here you go guys
come on
foreign
guys
they're gonna climb once they start
looking he's like I can climb I can do
this
it's okay
don't come out with your brother
Kristen and Grant have placed a pink
band on Harriet's leg so they're easier
to tell apart I said we've never been up
anything this big before this is a big
step for Harriet Tubman at this age they
need to be climbing out of their stump
stretching their wings jumping from
perches and getting to be big owls
look at him looking around Birds of Prey
always looking up to the highest place
oh
good job buddy
where are you gonna go now
that's what they do out the wild they
climb back up in the tree with their
beak and their talons so that they can
get back in the nest Harriet you're
doing just what you were supposed to do
I'm very proud of you
once we get these birds Wings stronger
their next step is taking live prey
you're gonna have to get down so we can
get out just come over onto this Branch
this is a good Branch for you come on
Harriet Tubman are actually at a
disadvantage not having parents to teach
them how to hunt so they're going to
have to learn how to do it on their own
[Music]
the orphan baby skunk rescued at the
nursery is in bad shape
today's vet visit will tell Brigette
just how bad this little skunk's
injuries really are when I bring skunks
to see Dr Jewell hey just in case our
skunk sprays we have our own special
table outside
let me tell you about this little girl
okay she had been orphaned for almost a
week they think that they had seen Mom
hit by a car
she did have some fly eggs and they were
on her little feet pads yeah yeah and I
also saw her back legs dragging okay can
she pee because that's the biggest
question with pine limb paralysis if
they've damaged the nerves either for
defecation or urination then that's when
we have a lot of trouble her bladder
feels pretty distended
yeah that's bladder very full
this little skunk has such a full
bladder which tells me that she probably
has not been able to go to the bathroom
on her own for quite some time and that
is very concerning to me let's go in and
then we'll get X-rays and see if we see
any fractures or abnormalities in the
spine
I'm really really hoping that this poor
little skunk does not have a severed
spine
if that's the case no matter how much I
want to help this little girl there's
nothing that we can do
what do you think could have caused it
with an animal that seems to be healthy
in every other way I would take some
sort of trauma possibly getting clipped
by a car if she was out wandering around
and just got bumped and not run over
everything's symmetrical it doesn't look
like anything shifted around alignment
too badly
the good news is I don't see any obvious
fractures or displacements of bone that
might indicate to me a more serious
trauma we could have just a neurologic
injury which may recover with care I
like that word recover today could have
gone either way with the X-ray and the
test results that I feel like all the
stars are lining up is definitely going
in the skunk's favor
I think it's worth a shot okay if we can
manage to keep her bladder expressed our
biggest concern is her ability to empty
her bowels and her bladder the nerves in
that lower spine can be affected to the
point that she cannot do that so that's
kind of our big issue hopefully things
will improve gradually okay and let me
know if something's going wrong okay I
get a little bit more emotionally
attached to the animals that are more of
the underdog this little skunk
definitely would be classified as an
underdog I am committed to doing
whatever it takes to get this little gal
back on her feet again we're gonna do it
we're gonna save her
[Music]
at the Western Kentucky Raptor Center
Bard owl's Harriet and Tubman are
mastering their flying skills let's see
how they're doing yeah I can't wait to
see them fly here's one oh there's the
other one how are you guys flying huh do
it Chapman
s have grown out of here
that'll be so exciting seeing Harriet
Tubman fly this is exactly what they're
supposed to be doing at this stage of
development
[Music]
foreign
it's very important that when we get
larger owls in as babies that we start
them in a small space and we gradually
move them into bigger spaces we don't
want them to stretch their wings too far
to begin with it takes little baby steps
ready Tubman you can hop up here
show your sister what you can do I'm
gonna put her over here see where she
wants to go
I'm gonna give them some time just to
get comfortable then when I come back
I'm going to bring them some live prey
to see how good they are at hunting
[Music]
all right guys
I brought you something
live mice a lot of people think that
it's cruel to feed live prey to things
but if I don't give these birds live
prey so that they learn how to hunt they
will starve to death
I guess since there's two of you I need
to put two in here don't I look at them
looking at it
there you go
[Music]
it's Harriet she's thinking about it
There She Goes
just not sure what to do are you
oh good job
she's a little clumsy but she did it I'm
really hoping that Tubman watches his
sister and learns from her kind of like
in a family the big sister teaches
little brother the ropes
he's thinking about it
Tubman don't let her show you up
Tubman dude right here
let me try it over here because Tubman
really likes to fly over here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you're still kind of Clueless dudes
[Music]
it's just easily distracted but he can't
focus
I know that Tubman is eventually gonna
get this that is the beauty of having
two baby bardous as long as he keeps
watching Harriet I think that he'll
learn how to do it
[Music]
at three months old the orphaned
raccoons have grown into curious little
troublemakers
ready to leave Nancy's babying behind
and begin survival training these little
raccoons it's amazing to see how fast
they grow
[Music]
because you know you put a lot of time
and work into them you've kind of bonded
with them a little bit I'm gonna miss
them but I'm not going to miss all the
work that goes along with it sometimes
I was just finishing up
[Music]
hi babies
it's been so long since I seen you y'all
gotten so big these raccoons are
juveniles now this is the time that the
mall would be taking them out and
showing them all the ropes but now I
kind of have to kick them in the butt
and get them more independent and ready
for the wild
I think we should just let them explore
for a little while and then come back
and put some food and water and they'll
be fine they'll just have food before
they came they're like let me out all
right come on check it out there's all
kinds of places to go
[Music]
it's always fun to see the raccoons
before the first time but there's a few
of them that are stuck on their mama
like you wouldn't believe are you gonna
get off mama
so you need to go play
while we do this at this stage they love
her they know that she's a safe place
but if he's raccoons they do attach to
humans they could not survive out in the
wild
time for some tough Nikki boot camp
[Music]
after a hopeful prognosis from the vet
Brigette is more determined than ever to
save her little paralyzed skunk
hold on
giving her a name fancy nerve damage is
very tricky sometimes it repairs itself
pretty quickly and sometimes it can't be
fixed all the way at all it's too early
for me to say what the end result will
be but I'm in for the Long Haul with her
since she can't go to the bathroom on
her own I'm just going to squeeze her
bladder because she needs to pee
oh biggie on
anybody that calls me crazy for
expressing a skunk splatter and bowels
that's fine but if we don't make her go
to the bathroom that could be the
difference between her life and her
death I think she bit her tail
foreign
do you mind to give me a hand over here
when an animal comes in like fancy I
have to observe them so much more than I
would just a healthy animal coming in
any slight change behavior is a red flag
that something else could be going on
you can let her just sit down here yep
just like this exactly
I think the feeling is coming back in
her tail and she bit it
fancy biting her tail is a catch-22 I
hate that she bit the tail however this
is a great sign it means that she's
starting to have feeling back in her
tail again do you think she'll be able
to walk I would love it if she can have
limited Mobility even just to walk for
short periods of time
I really really want this little skunk
to walk again so another very important
thing that I have to do daily is
physical therapy with her
I'm gonna do is just push in on her legs
just a little bit
this helps keep all the muscles working
internally not just her legs but it
helps her to be able to go to the
bathroom on her own and of course we
want her to do that independently
I feel a tiny bit of resistance there
they're not quite the lymph noodles as
they used to be I'm starting to see some
signs of movement on her own we're
definitely heading in the right
direction
good job fancy
hi guys you help me pull these eggs
please at Nikki's survival boot camp the
orphaned raccoons are about to get their
paws dirty I want to see if they can
actually open these eggs I want to see
those little hands working and pulling
them open the egg goes in the middle and
then put a little bit of peanut butter
on the edge I just want to be able to
smell the peanut butter and I'm hoping
it kind of you know entices them to kind
of dig and open them up
let's add the eggs and have our own
little Easter egg hunt rocking their
scavengers in the wild they're gonna
have to open nuts they're going to have
to open eggs up
Easter eggs or just a quick easy way for
me to be able to see what they can do
good morning loves
you can grab that dirt Jay
appreciate it
here we play
if you'll take a couple of seconds from
back there and then take the rest here
I'm pulling you know some dirt on it I
want them to hunt for it just a little
bit
by foraging for things like insects
snakes and even dead rodents raccoons
help clean up the environment
yeah
[Music]
makes our little hands go like Non-Stop
[Music]
oh I like the fact that they're trying
to bite some of them too open
[Music]
it come on
[Music]
uh-huh he's got it open good job buddy
laughs
I'll open it come on open it there's
another one there's two
oh those little thousands that have
never anything in their fingers this is
what they're for
good job buddy
I think they're all doing pretty dang
good job
they've done everything that I need them
to do
they need a couple more weeks to grow
and they'll be out the door they rocked
it they didn't take long for those
little hands start working and open
those eggs and find those awesome treats
that I had for them if they keep on
doing all the things Dusty I'm doing
right now by the end of summer they'll
be ready to be released
[Music]
she has pooped on her own that's a huge
huge step for her
good job fancy
woohoo fancy pooped on her own today
that is such a huge hurdle that she is
now over
we'll go for swim time now that fancy
has improved she's gonna go First Swim
water therapy is a really good thing to
do for animals that can't really hold up
their own body weight in the water all
that weight just disappears and it
allows freedom to move the muscles
there you go
skunks have a natural instinct to do
what is similar to a doggy paddle
I'm really not seeing her legs move at
all just a little more just a little
more
I was really hopeful when putting fancy
in the pool that her legs would
automatically move unfortunately I'm not
seeing that at all
I think she's getting kind of tired I
think she's done for today so even
though she was able to go to the
bathroom now I'm coming to the reality
that fancy is probably not going to make
her way back into the wild that does
make me a little sad
she's a good girl
[Music]
after several failed attempts barred owl
Tubman still can't seem to catch his own
dinner what are we gonna do with him
Harriet
Kristen hopes the move to an even larger
space will finally get him hunting like
his adopted sister Harriet Tubman you
got to be able to go with your sister
taking live prey is the final step that
these birds need to take to be released
back out in the wild again yes I know
Harriet you're ready for your food
Harriet has totally mastered hunting but
Tubman just doesn't get it so my plan
today is putting out several mice will
hope that Harriet catches hers and then
Tubman watches and learns
[Music]
here she goes
your share would you like to just share
that Mouse with me because I'm kind of a
lazy Hunter yeah just just give me that
one she's not going to feed you dude
I don't know what's going on with Tubman
he's watched Harriet do it he is totally
capable of doing it and he's just not
doing it
all right Harriet
you gotta come with me I'm thinking if I
remove Harriet Tubman May step up his
gate I know it's not fair is it
if Tubman doesn't take live prey it not
only pushes back his release but it also
pushes back Harriet's release in the
wild they would have Nest mates that
they would go out with so it's very
important not only to me but to them
that they be released together so I'm in
you ready
let's try this
[Music]
I'm not sure why Tubman is testing my
patients so much but I have to make sure
that he can take live prey I'm running
out of options but the survival depends
on it
all right Tubman Grant and I are going
to talk about this see what our plan G
is with you
[Music]
an hour and a half away Brigette has
come up with a new way for fancy to get
around
just because fancy can't walk doesn't
mean that she needs to be confined into
a small little cage I'm going to help
her out and make a sweet little Chariot
for fancy to use for walking this is my
very first attempt at making wheels to
help her get around this a little bit
better
she's so little right now companies just
don't make itty-bitty wheelchair carts
for these animals
this is the cutest little shin guard it
belonged to my son when he was three
he's now 19. I just happen to find these
and I think this will be great to put
her little body in if I just attach some
wheels on here
fancy is a sweet little skunk she's a
great patient but I have to say I'm very
curious how she's going to react it's
not every day I try to swish a little
baby skunk into a wheelchair this all
sounds so good in theory we'll see if it
works
Tubman the barred owl's inability to
hunt live prey has put both his and
Harriet's release in Jeopardy all right
Tubman you ready if I'm gonna release
these two barred owls together the clock
is really ticking for Tubman I know he's
capable of doing it he's watched Harriet
do it he just needs to take the stinking
live prey
you have no idea how many times I've
been out here trying to give him one
prey and he just won't do it and I don't
know if he's intimidated because I'm in
here but I don't want to release one
without the other
okay so we'll put up these cameras and
we'll leave and then we can watch from
the outside yeah hopefully this works
keeping my fingers crossed all right so
it occurred to Grant and I that out in
the wild there's not gonna be humans
standing there watching ever take live
prey so we decided to set up cameras and
we'll watch from outside the door
all right you have the phone synced up
yeah fancy schmancy
come on buddy get it
oh oh look look all right oh okay you
got that one yeah let's see if he's
gonna come back and get the second one
awesome all right we got both of them
yeah he got both of them he did good he
did good he knew
which it just wasn't gonna do when I was
watching but little did he know I was
watching this great news this is awesome
now they can go together
survival school is over for the orphaned
raccoons all right guys it's time to go
and graduation day is finally here these
raccoons have surpassed every test that
I have given them there is no doubt in
my mind to be able to survive and thrive
in the wild remember monkey
oh yeah
[Music]
she's doing so big I have the perfect
location for me to release these guys we
have about 200 Acres of our famous
property and just about five minutes
away from the house I think these
raccoons are going to do amazing
all right Jay
grab the dog food since you're stronger
than I am
I do a soft release on all my animals
it's just the way that I do this I
usually bring some type of dog food just
so they have a backup until they find
their food source see it underneath that
log put some underneath there and find a
place somewhere there so no matter what
direction they can still find some food
these raccoons are actually going to
love these logs there's all kinds of
little crevices and places they can hide
it's near the water source near the
woods so it's all around perfect for
them
hi baby all right I know I know
[Music]
you can go ahead and open that door I
think
it's a new crazy world
oh new spells
there he goes being a wildlife rehabber
is not just a job for me this is my
heart and my soul I taught these
raccoons everything that I could and the
fact that they are where they're at
right now today because of what I've
done it makes me feel great bye guys
it's a big day for fancy the skunk her
wheels are ready and she's about to take
her first test drive and make your car
baby you can walk with this
fancy has come a long way since I first
rescued her and she is even more special
now because she is the very first skunk
ever at Second Chances to have a
wheelchair
there you go
come on fancy
[Music]
There She Goes come on babies
yay
[Music]
good girl
going she's going
I'm very pleased with today's first
attempt at her Wheels she doesn't seem
to be struggling she's not fighting to
get out I don't think she's overly
stressed
[Applause]
good girl
when she gets a little bit bigger a
little bit more confident in her Wheels
I'll be able to take her out to show
children that might have physical
impairments themselves I would much
prefer to release all the skunks that
come into me because they do play an
important role in the environment
Fancy's role is going to be a little bit
different but every bit as important she
is going to become an educational
Ambassador she will go teach children
and adults the importance of Wildlife
come here sweet thing good job good job
[Music]
after being under Kristen's protective
Wing Bard owl's Harriet and Tubman are
finally ready to soar and Harriet
good job you're awesome I'm so proud of
Harriet and tuppin that's probably why
you're the goalie on soccer team huh
they have mastered every skill that
they're going to need in the wild they
went from climbing to Flying to hunting
Library I have no doubt in my mind that
these owls are going to do great in the
wild
here goes your pink band
you don't need this anymore it doesn't
matter who's who in the wild
goodbye Western Kentucky Raptor Center
hello big beautiful world
[Music]
I'm sure there are tons of mice out here
oh yeah with all these cornfields
soybean Fields they're gonna have more
mice and rodents than they could
possibly want
there are trees there are Woods there
are Open Fields this is the perfect spot
to release Harriet Tubman on three or on
go
on three got it
one one two three
[Music]
go go go go go go go go go
I tried to teach my children that we're
very much doing something good for the
world we're all part of that beautiful
circle of life and what's important is
that we all do our part Harriet Tubman
are going to do theirs and I've done
mine
oh
[Music]
[Music]